Hi. Welcome back.
In this, my second session on market
timing, I want to talk about some of the
indicators people use to try to time
markets.
I will look at non-financial indicators
and what they are, as well as technical
indicators, things we've talked about in
the context of charting.
So, let's start with non-financial
indicators.
Non-financial indicators, as I said,
don't show up in your Wall Street
Journal or maybe in your stock price
pages, but I would classify
non-financial indicators into three
groups. The first are what I would term
spurious indicators, things that look
like they're correlated with the market,
but have no reasonable basis for it.
Now, we look at what's, uh, for
instance, the Super Bowl indicator. What
does that mean? Why does it work? You
know, if it does work, what does it tell
us?
The feel-good indicator measures how
happy investors are feeling. Presumably,
happy investors are more likely to push
up prices.
I'm not sure whether that's a good sign
or a bad sign, but many people actually
feel that if people are feeling too
good, they get hyped up. That's a sign
of a market bubble. There's going to be
a correction coming. So, let's start
with spurious indicators.
There are dozens and dozens of
indicators that people claim tell you
what's going to happen in the market.
Now, when you look at the statistics
backing it up, most of the time the
research is, "This is beyond the reach
of statistics." And standing alone, that
is actually true.
For a long time, for instance, we talk
about the Super Bowl indicators. Those
of you don't know how the Super Bowl
works, the Super Bowl is an American
football phenomenon,
where the winner of There are two
divisions
in American football, the NFC and the
AFC.
And the winner of each division meets at
the end of the Super Bowl, one of the
most, um,
talked about, watched phenomena in
sports, perhaps only second to the World
Cup.
And one of the things researchers
noticed, at least until very recently,
was if that Super Bowl match-up was won
by the AFC team. AFC and NFC are the two
divisions. Markets are more likely to go
up.
So, as an early example of how
researchers presented this, here's how
it go.
There've been 35 Super Bowls played in
and in 28 of those 35, this indicator
worked at predicting what the market
would do. In other words, AFC or the
NFC.
Now, 28 out of 35 is too high to be pure
chance, and technically that is true.
That beats the 50/50, which you'd expect
with randomness. But, here's the
problem.
If you have hundreds and hundreds of
things out there, indicators that you
have data on, and you try all all of
them, some of them will beat the odds of
chance, even if they're purely driven by
luck.
Second,
some of these spurious indicators give
you a sense of market direction. For
instance, uh you'll you'll hear that if
happens, markets are more likely to go
up than down. Remember, up and down is a
pretty weak prediction. A market going
up 5% might not be a good year.
It's so many of these indicators don't
look at do these markets go up more than
expected or less than expected.
And finally, if you find an indicator
where there's no economic rationale. And
again, I hate to go back to the Super
Bowl indicator, but I'll go back to it.
There is no economic story you can tell
for why
there should be a link between who wins
that game
and what happens to stock prices. So,
spurious indicators are indicators that
look good on paper, but almost never
work in practice, partly because they're
entirely driven by chance.
Let's move on to feel-good indicators.
Let's start with a statement that I
think is true. When people feel upbeat,
they feel optimistic,
they push up stock prices because that
optimism feeds in there, but it also
affects the rest of what they do, the
styles and the social mode.
The 1920s, for instance, good time for
markets, of course, was also the period
where
Americans partied. They felt good.
1950s, the same way.
So, over time, it's not surprising that
people have found a link between social
indicators and Wall Street.
Now, I saw one that claimed that if you
know how many bankers are eating at
high-priced restaurants in New York
City, you can tell me what the market is
doing, and that's true. There is a high
correlation between demand for
high-priced food and services in New
York City and how well the market is
doing because much of the demand is
coming from people who work in financial
markets, and when markets are doing
well, they're more likely to be doing
well as well.
But, here's the catch.
That's a contemporaneous correlation.
You're saying, "What does that even
mean?"
Well, when markets are doing well,
people party more, right?
But, knowing that people are partying
more is not helping you on markets
because your job as an investor is to
get ahead of the game.
You need a lagging indicator
the markets to be lagging your
indicators so you can observe the
indicator and say, "That's what's going
to happen to markets next year." You'll
see that as a common theme in much of
market timing. Knowing that something is
correlated with markets is not useful if
it's contemporaneous. It happens the
same time. You need to get ahead of the
game to be able to time markets based on
that indicator.
Third, there are hype indicators. The
essence of a bubble is people are hyped
up. They're driving up prices. They're
being irrational.
And there are arguments to be made that
when there is a fad and investors get
caught up in the fad, it's going to show
up elsewhere.
It's a classic indicator used in Wall
Street, so all the cocktail party
chatter indicator, which is when you go
to a cocktail party, how quickly does
the talk turn to stocks? In New York, it
turns to stocks almost immediately.
But, let's say in Des Moines, Iowa,
and 2 minutes into a cocktail party,
people start talking about stocks.
That's an indicator that hype has risen
to the surface. A variant of this
is how quickly your Uber driver, or
whoever your ride-sharing driver is,
starts talking about stocks. The
argument being that if, you know, and
and there's an old
John F. Kennedy's father was a legendary
investor in Wall Street in presumably
got off got out of the market before the
correction, before the great, you know,
the great correction. And the story is
he knew that it was time to get out of
the market when the shoeshine boy, at
those times, you had people set up
shoeshine stations on the street, and
people who were going to work would stop
and get their shoe When a shoeshine boy
started talking about which stocks to
buy.
That's a hype indicator.
And as investors turn to social media,
what's cocktail party, the Uber driver,
the the shoeshine boy is being replaced
by what are people saying on Twitter?
That the same hype that drives that the
old indicators is now showing up in what
people tweet. So, maybe by looking at
social media, you get a sense of how
much hype is driving it.
Now, of course, the you know, while
there is some basis for hype indicators,
deciding what's unusual can be tricky to
do. What's an unusually upbeat
mood on markets? That I mean, defining
abnormal can be tricky when what's
normal keeps shifting, when standards
and tastes are changing.
And even if you can observe a hype
indicator, that things are getting hyped
up, I'm not sure how you follow through.
You think that must mean there's there's
a correction coming?
You might be right, but what if it takes
5 years between the time you observe an
indicator and the correction happens?
So, hype indicators might work, but
there's there might be no timeliness in
when they work.
So, those are the non-financial
indicators.
The second group of indicators are
indicators we talked about in the
context of individual stocks that might
be used to time markets, technical
indicators.
Now,
as with individual stocks, there's a
tension here between the momentum and
the reversal players. So, if you
remember technical indicators broadly
grouped, you have momentum indicators
who believe that what's happened in the
past is more likely to continue into the
future. And reversal indicators who
think that if things have been really
good in the past, there's going to be a
correction coming. The same tension
plays out in markets where the same
indicator can be bullish for one group
and bearish for the other.
In addition with the market, people find
information in trading volume just as
they do with the individual stocks. A
surging volume or a drop in volume might
be a good or a bad sign that you bring
into views in the markets.
As well as where the market volatility
goes up and down, side indicators that
you can observe by looking at other
instruments in the market.
So, broadly speaking, is there
information in knowing what the market
has done in the last year, the last 2
years in predicting what the market will
do in the future? Here's what I did to
try to answer that question.
I have over 153 years of stock prices
and I thank Robert Shiller for putting
that data going back to 1871 here.
I took the 153 years and broke them down
into what stocks do after a down year
and an up year. Let's focus on the down
year and the up year first. There were
36 down years and 36 up years. Just one
down year, one up year. Right?
The return in the following year was
10.14% after a down year, 12.05% after
an up year. Statistically, those are
very similar.
If you have two up years, right?
Then, numbers start to shift. It turns
out that the next year is more likely to
be a bad year. The return is only 1.78%.
You say, "There, I have my strategy.
If there are two up years, I'm going to
sell stocks." Well, the problem is after
two down years,
your returns are also not really good.
So, two down years and two up years are
both bad news. Already, you can see
without even digging deeper and deeper
into this data that the the the more you
get into the depths of the data, the
more confused you're going to be because
the patterns are shifting and there's no
clear signal you're getting by looking
what markets did in the last year. Now,
you can try this by quarter, by month,
but one of the things you're going to
see is timing markets based purely on
what markets have done in the past has
not worked that well.
Now, there's also a variant of that. If
you remember when we talked about timing
patterns, we talked about the January
effect that the Jan- the January
historically has been the best month of
the year. In fact, all of the small cap
premium we talked about came in January.
So, usually the way people present this
argument is if you know what happened in
January, you can predict what the year
will look like. And technically, you're
right. A bad January usually goes with a
bad year for stocks and a good January
goes with a good year for stocks. You
say, "This is good. I'll wait till the
end of January, and if January is a good
if I have a good January, stocks are up
a lot, then I'm going to invest in
stocks. And if stocks are down in
January,
I will not invest in stocks." Here's the
problem.
While it's true that January returns are
correlated with the returns over the
overall year, remember by the time you
observe January returns, January is
already behind you. You're going to
invest from February through December.
And if you look at those 11 months, the
signal becomes much weaker.
Put simply, I can't really
statistically show you that the returns
in the remaining 11 months are going to
be any different whether you have a good
January or bad January, they kind of
even out.
January indicator looks good at first
sight, not so good if you take a deeper
look. What about trading volume?
Here the story is cut both ways. There's
an argument that if you see stocks per
stock prices going up but with light
trading volume, that's a bearish sign.
There's a correction coming.
At the same time, there are people who
argue that if you see very heavy trading
volume, there's a correction coming as
well.
You think, "That's contradictory." One
of the things about technical indicators
is they are contradictory. The same
indicator can give different signals to
different traders depending on their
perspective of that indicator. So,
trading volume affects prices, yes, but
is it Is it a
Is the relationship something you can
use to time markets? I'm not sure. Maybe
you can find it as you start digging
through intraday or daily or weekly
trading volume.
There might also be information in the
option market. Remember we talked about
index futures in the context of
arbitrage and index options.
Now, remember when people get upbeat
about stocks, they might buy call
options, a leveraged bet on stocks going
up. And if they feel pessimistic, they
might buy put options.
There are people who observe the rate
the trading volume on puts versus the
trading volume on calls.
So, it becomes a contrarian indicator.
When the trading volume in puts picks up
relative to calls, people are getting
more pessimistic,
there are people out there who view that
as a sign that the market is going to
turn around. Again, data and trading
volume either in the market stock market
itself or in the option market.
There are also people who observe money
flow.
At the risk of stating the obvious, if
money is coming into markets, I don't
know from where, that's a good sign.
Stocks are more likely to go up. So, if
you can find indicators of that money
flow,
both the direction and the amount, it
might help you predict markets. So,
let's say your indicator tells you that
money flow is going to go up that it's
going to flow into the market over the
next 6 months for whatever reason. You
might buy stocks because that money flow
is highly correlated with returns. But
that correlation is again
contemporaneous. In periods when money
flows into markets, stocks tend to go
up. But for you to make money on money
flow, that's not sufficient, right? You
got to forecast what money flow is going
to look like in the next 6 months in the
next year. And if you can do that, there
is there is informa- there is at least
backing to the notion that you might be
able to time markets.
There
There are researchers who extended the
study to global equity markets and they
find evidence of momentum. That when
prices are going up, they're more likely
to go up. Prices are going down, they're
more likely to go down across
geographies.
But they find that the evidence is
stronger in high trading volume markets
and weaker in low trading volume
markets.
Finally,
volatility matters. And until about 40
years ago, we talked about volatility,
but it was not observable. You couldn't
trade on it.
But in the mid '80s, you had indices
that allowed you to trade not at the
level of the market, but on market
volatility. The most widely used of
these indices is called the VIX, the
volatility index.
And basically, it's a bet on what the
volatility of the market will be.
So, that number might So, let's assume
the VIX is 25 and that's what the
historical number has been. You're
around the average VIX. And usually when
people draw high, low, or typical
numbers, they're drawing it based on
history.
So, this is a study that looked at what
happens when the VIX is much higher than
expected bas- based on with expectations
based on the past and much lower than
expected.
In the period where the VIX jumps,
it increases,
it's not good for stocks. You see stock
prices go down. Right?
In periods where the VIX decreases,
stock prices go up. So, in in the
contemporaneous period, an increase in
VIX goes with lower stock prices.
For those of you watch markets, this
shouldn't come as a surprise. The days
where the market is down are the days
where the VIX jumps.
But, you can't make money on it. It's
contemporaneous.
But, here's where it gets interesting.
When the VIX increases, bad news for
stock prices now, but historically, it's
been good news in terms of what stocks
do in the subsequent period. So, when
volatility increases, it turns out that
stocks do much better in the subsequent
period.
When volatility decreases, stocks do not
as well in the subsequent period. And
that's a tradeable
strategy. You look at the VIX, it's
higher than expected,
you buy stocks. It's lower than
expected, you sell stocks.
Whether you will make enough money to
cover transactions costs and taxes,
that's going to be a tricky question
because these are not big surges in
returns, 1 and 1/2%.
It's not something that you can just use
to cover up large transactions costs,
but there is clearly a link between
volatility and what you see happening to
markets.
There are a whole set of other
indicators that I won't go through
because all of those chart patterns we
talked about with the individual stocks
can also be used at the market level.
Remember support and resistance lines?
There are people who use support and
resistance lines for the entire market,
trend lines for the market. Again, the
battle between momentum and reversal
plays out in these chart patterns.
There are also what I call sentiment
indicators. What do sentiment indicators
try to capture? The fear, greed. They're
trying to
you know, measure the balance between
fear and greed.
They're trying to see how fearful are
people getting because they're getting
fearful stock prices should go down.
I'll give you a simple example
of a sentiment indicator.
It's called the confidence index. So,
you compare the yield on a triple B
rated bond. That's at the very edge of
investment grade
to a triple A rated bond or to even to a
treasury bond. As people get more
scared, the spreads increase.
Not surprisingly, and when the spreads
increase, it turns out that risk
premiums in equity markets also go up,
which pushes down stock prices,
sentiment indicators.
And finally, there are indicators of
what the traders' sentiment is. Are they
getting bullish or bearish? And people
again use this either as an indicator
that, you know, bullishness will carry
over as a contrarian indicator.
So, remember mutual fund cash positions.
We talked about this as a way in which,
you know, mutual funds decide stocks are
not, you know, the place to be. You You
put it into cash.
So, when mutual funds get down on
markets, they get bearish, they increase
their cash positions as a percentage of
total hoard. There are people who track
mutual fund cash holdings. And if
they're contrarians, here's what they
do. When mutual funds get more bearish,
the cash holding goes up.
They say They buy stocks because they
say mutual funds are getting more
bearish, that's a good sign for markets.
Same with investment advisers. You know,
when they get more bullish, that's
viewed as a If you're a contrarian, as a
bad sign for markets. So, again, dozens
and dozens of other indicators, but the
bottom line with all of these indicators
again
is you got to ask two questions. One is
are the indicators leading indicators?
Do they tell you what's coming? Are they
contemporaneous? You want leading
indicators. Second, how strong is the
linkage? How noisy is it? Because if
you're going to be right only one time
out of 10, it might not be enough. And
third, will the returns you make by
following these indicators cover the
transactions costs and taxes that come
from trading more frequently?
So, here's the bottom line on, you know,
finan- uh non-financials and technical
indicators. There are dozens, perhaps
even hundreds of indicators
that are correlated with market
movements. And we can see that up front.
But, for you to be able to make money on
them, first they have to be observable.
So, you have a hype indicator where you
say, "You got to observe the mood of
people." You can't I I you can't go
around gauging people's moods. So, you
got to use something that I can use to
observe the mood.
Second, they have to lead markets.
Again, I hate to sound like a broken
record, but to make money on an
indicator, it's not enough that the
indicator moves with markets, but that
observing the indicator tells you what
markets will do in the next period. And
finally, it's got to be big enough to
cover transactions costs and trading
costs.
Most of the analysts that are Most of
the indicators that I see analysts using
to time markets tend to be
contemporaneous rather than leading
and not useful as investment signals.
So, you need to separate the signals
from the noise.
And I hope you succeed.
I hope you found the session useful, and
I thank you very much for listening.